in this video we're going to go through
six examples where we're given six
different tables and we have to identify
whether it's linear equation or if it's
a quadratic equation or if it's an
exponential equation we're going to be
working with these three formulas right
here we're also going to be talking
about the method of finite differences
so see if you can do some of these on
your own we'll go through all six
together let's dive into the first
example you can see here that the X
values are consecutive meaning one after
another like that and when they're like
that we can use a technique called
method of finite differences with the Y
coordinates and the way we do this is we
subtract
negative 3 minus negative 5 which is 2
negative 1 minus negative 3 which is 2 1
minus negative 1 is 2 and 3 minus 1 is
2. now you can do it where you subtract
the number on the right minus the one on
the left or you can do it the one on the
left minus the one on the right the key
thing is that you want to be consistent
so if you're doing left minus right you
do that all the way down or if you do
right minus left you do that all the way
down
if you get the same number on the first
time that you subtract okay that tells
you that it's a first degree equation if
you had to subtract a second time to get
the same number a constant then that
tells you it's a second degree
polynomial equation and then if you had
to do it a third time it would be a
third degree like a cubic equation Etc
so that's one way to identify whether
it's a linear quadratic but as far as an
exponential function goes you could keep
doing that method of finite differences
forever it will never give you that
constant okay like you're getting with
the first degree second degree third
degree polynomial equations what you're
looking for here is where you're going
to actually be multiplying by the same
quantity to get to the next y value so
we'll see some examples like that but
for this one since the first time we
subtracted we got a constant the same
number each time that tells us that it's
linear and remember linear is the
equation of a line Y equals MX plus b so
when you think about this you can think
okay I'm going up by 2H time every time
the uh y's go up by two the X's go up by
one and remember the slope is the change
in y over the change in X so this is a
positive 2 over a positive one which is
2. so that's going to be y equals the
slope which is 2x plus b now the B here
is our y-intercept this is where it
crosses the y-axis that's this point
right here because when you think about
0 negative 3 you're going zero left or
right on the x-axis you're just going
down 3 and so that's going to give us
the B value of negative 3. now I like to
kind of check my answer so you might
want to do the same thing is maybe plug
in the point for example let's say if I
put in 3 for x 2 times 3 is 6 minus 3 is
3 and you can see it matches so
sometimes I like to just check to make
sure I'm on the right track let's look
at another example okay for example
number two let's take a look at the
method of finite differences and see if
this is a first degree second degree
third degree like that so if I do the
right minus the left negative 3 minus 0
I get negative 3 negative 4 minus
negative 3 is like negative 4 plus 3 so
that's negative 1 and negative 3 minus
negative 4 is like negative 3 plus 4. so
that's positive one and zero minus
negative 3 is like 0 plus 3 which gives
us positive three now you can see we're
not getting the same number the first
time that we subtracted so it's not a
first degree equation let's try
subtracting again so I'm going to do
negative 1 minus negative 3 that's like
negative 1 plus 3 which is 2 1 minus
negative 1 is like 1 plus 1 that's 2 and
3 minus 1 is 2. so you can see we're
getting two two two two now it doesn't
really matter the number whether it's
five five five five or nine nine nine
nine or twelve twelve right it's the
fact that the second time that we
subtracted we're getting the same number
so that tells us as a second degree
equation it's a quadratic equation in
this form now when we look at the table
there's a couple different ways of doing
this one way is we can make a system of
equations and solve for a b and c
another way to do it is we can look at
what we call the zeros now what are the
zeros the zeros are these points right
here
and if you were to graph this you would
see that the quadratic which is a
parabola shape is going to cross the
x-axis at negative one see that's where
the Y value is zero and at positive
three
that's also where the Y value is zero so
what we can do is we can make use of
What's called the intercept form
intercept form is this form here y
equals a times x minus P times x minus Q
or p and Q are the X intercepts or the
zeros
so let's go ahead and work with this one
we have y equals a x minus negative 1 is
X Plus 1 x minus 3 okay is our other
Factor now how do we figure out what a
is well we could pick another point for
example maybe let's say this point here
zero negative three I'll put negative 3
in for y I'll put 0 in for the X
variable and we can solve for this a a
is like the stretch or Shrink or reflect
of the parabola so this comes out to
negative 3 equals a times 1 times
negative three so you can see we're
getting negative 3 equals negative 3 a
so a must equal one so if we divide by
negative three you can see a is equal to
one so let's put this one
back in right here okay so this comes
out to y equals 1 times X plus one times
x minus three
and now I'm just going to multiply this
out so of course 1 times anything is
itself so I'm just going to multiply x
times x which is x squared x times
negative 3 is a negative 3x 1 times x is
X and 1 times negative 3 is negative 3
and again like I said 1 times anything
is itself let's combine like terms here
and we're getting y equals x squared
minus 2x minus 3 and that's the equation
of our quadratic given this table let's
take a look at another example okay for
number three now let's take a look at
this pattern
when I look at this I can do the method
of finite differences like we did in the
first and second example but what I
notice here is it looks like I'm
multiplying by well actually looks like
I'm dividing by 3 right 6 divided by 3
is 2 2 divided by 3 is 2 3. 54 divided
by 3 is 18. dividing by 3 is the same as
multiplying by the reciprocal one-third
so this when you're multiplying by the
same number each time to get to the next
y value and X Y value and X Y value that
tells you that it's an exponential
equation and this V value this base is
what we're multiplying by in this case
the one-third so what we have is y
equals a
times 1 3 to the X power now how do we
solve for this a well the a is the
y-intercept it's where it crosses the
y-axis and when you're crossing the
y-axis like if this is a graph like this
you can see it's Crossing at the y-axis
when X is zero so when X is zero Y is
equal to two and so that means our a
value is 2. so y equals two times
one-third to the X power and you've got
it now you might want to check maybe put
in some other values like say for
example 1 1 3 to the first is one-third
and one-third times two is two-thirds
that makes sense right so let's try
another example
okay before we dive into the last three
examples which I'd like for you to try
to practice on your own and by the way
for number four five and six I mix them
up you know it's not the same order that
I did the first three like linear
quadratic exponential I kind of mixed
them up so this way you can kind of test
yourself to make sure you understand but
what I wanted to tell you is if you're
like the way that I explain things and
you'd like to go deeper and learn more
about Algebra 1 and Algebra 2 or college
algebra
I put a link in the video description
box below so go ahead and check out
those video courses that I have for sale
I take you step by step through a
typical Algebra 1 class or typical
Algebra 2 class with lots of examples
lots of explanation of the concepts so
check those out if you're learning those
courses or want to review those courses
but let's dive into number four now so
what would you do on this one pause the
video and see if you can do it if I was
going to do it I would do that method of
finite differences first so I do 4 minus
11 is negative seven one minus 4 is
negative 3 2 minus 1 is 1 and 7 minus 2
is 5. I didn't get the same number on
that first time I subtracted so I know
it's not a first degree equation like
linear so let me subtract a second time
negative 3 minus negative seven is four
and you can do this on the calculator if
that helps you just kind of keep track
of all the pauses and negatives but when
you subtract a negative it's like adding
the opposite and notice we're getting
the same number each time on that second
time you subtracted that tells us it's a
second degree equation it's going to be
a quadratic equation see this second
degree exponent there
so what we're going to do on this
problem is we're going to write a system
of equations so we'll do this method
where we're going to make write three
equations I'm going to take these three
points right here 0 1 1 2 and 2 7. so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to say
well if Y is 1 okay that's going to be 1
equals x is 0 so that's going to be a
times 0 squared plus b times 0 plus C
okay then I'm going to take the second
Point put 2 in for y and 1 in for x
and then I'm going to take the third
point I'm going to put 7 in for
Y and I'm going to put 2 in for x
okay now let's go ahead and simplify
this down a little bit
0 squared is 0 times a is 0. B times 0
is 0 0 plus 0 is 0. so we're just left
with C is equal to 1. so that's
interesting so we already know what c is
now for the second equation 1 squared is
1 times a is a
plus b times 1 is B plus C is equal to
2. now remember we said c is equal to
one so I'm going to replace this C with
one and I'm going to subtract 1 from
both sides so we've got a plus b equals
one okay so that's interesting let's
keep track of that equation and then for
the last one 2 squared is 4 times a is
4A plus 2B
plus C which we said is 1 is equal to 7.
okay so if I subtract one this is equal
to six so we have four a plus two B is
equal to six so now look what we have
we've got two variables two equations we
want to solve that system right so let's
say we want to eliminate the B's I'm
going to multiply this equation by
negative two this way we'll have 2B and
negative 2B so if I do that to the
entire equation that's going to give us
negative 2A minus 2B equals negative two
and if we add straight down here you can
see we get 2A the B's cancel and if we
divide by two a is equal to two
okay so now we know A and C we just need
to find out what B is so let's go ahead
and put 2 back in for a here or you can
do this one here let's just do this one
though so this would be 2 plus b is
equal to one subtract 2 from both sides
so B is equal to negative one so now
we've got our a b and c we can plug that
in for a b and c here and we have our
equation so let's see what that is
that's going to be y equals 2 x squared
minus 1 X plus one
and that's our quadratic equation so
let's look at another example
see if you can pause the video and do
example number five and we'll go through
it together so if I was going to do this
one what I'm noticing here is that if I
multiply negative 3 times 2 I get
negative 6 and If I multiply negative 6
times 2 I get negative 12. and let me
check over here negative 3 4 times 2 is
negative 3 halves and negative three
halves times two is negative 3. so I'm
continuously multiplying by 2 and when
you're multiplying by the same number
each time that tells you that it's an
exponential function and that base B is
going to be equal to 2. so what we have
is y equals a
times 2 to the X power now the a
represents the y-intercept and the
y-intercept is where X is equal to zero
so this is a negative 3 so this is going
to be y equals negative 3 times 2 to the
X power and you got it now I always like
to check so let's say for example if I
put 2 in 2 squared is 4 times negative 3
yeah that matches negative 12. let's
take a look at the last example okay see
if you can pause the video and do this
last example and see what you get so if
I was going to do this problem
I would use a method of finite
differences so if I do negative 2 minus
negative 4 that's 2 and 0 minus negative
2 that's 2 and 2 minus 0 is 2 and 4
minus 2 is 2. notice that we're getting
the same number on the first time that
we subtracted that tells us that it's a
first degree
equation y equals MX plus b a line a
linear equation and you can see that the
Y's are going up by 2 as the X's are
going up by one so two over one is a
slope of 2. so this is y equals 2x plus
b now in this case we don't know what
our y-intercept is because we don't see
where x equals 0 here on our table so
what we could do is we could just pick a
point let's maybe say this point right
here if I put 0 in for y and I put
negative 3 in for X I can solve for this
B value so let's go ahead and do that
6 and B look very similar negative 6
plus b so if we add 6 to both sides you
can see that b
our y-intercept is equal to 6. so if we
take that 6 and we put it right in here
for B we've got our linear equation y
equals 2x plus 6. again if you want to
check it let's put in a point like
negative five two times negative 5 is
negative 10 plus 6 is negative 4 it
matches so we know we've got a good
equation here so great job if you want
to see more examples or you want to get
some more practice I'll put a video
right there that I did going through
more of these follow me over to that
video and we'll do some more examples
together